[Music]
do you know which is the hardest
mountain to climb you would probably say
Mount Everest since it's the highest
mountain but that is incorrect the
hardest one is the second highest
mountain k2 due to the difficulty of its
ascent it's called the savage Mountain
it is harder to climb k2 because we know
that along with height there are many
other factors to consider steepness is
one of them for example let's consider
these two mountains the right one
clearly has more altitude but the left
one will be harder to climb as it's
deeper now let me ask you a question
what do we mean by steepness for example
consider these two straight lines which
one is steeper here the difference is
subtle but we can see that it's the
second one but can you think of a way to
concretely prove that the second one is
steeper one simple way is to draw the
horizontal and vertical lines like this
measure the lengths and find the ratio
of the vertical length to the horizontal
length on substituting the values we get
1 and 1.5 the second ratio is clearly
greater what does this tell us
if we walk along these lines this ratio
tells us how much vertical distance we
cover relative to the horizontal
distance so if the ratio is higher it
means that the slant line is steeper we
can also see this as the distance
covered while going up per unit of the
distance while going across there's
another way to know which line is
steeper and that is to find this angle
greater the angle steeper will be the
line but notice that these two lines are
connected to the angle by the
trigonometric tangent function
this ratio is equal to tan theta one and
this is equal to tan theta two such a
ratio for a straight line is called its
slope it is the measure of the steepness
of the line now look at this curve what
is the slope of this curve does it even
make sense to ask this what do you think
in this video will understand what this
means here the process of
differentiation helps us also we know
that such a curve can be represented
algebraically by a function between two
variables we will see that this slope is
connected to the idea of the derivative
of a function so let's continue with our
question one thing we can clearly see
here is that different positions of the
curve will have different steepness we
can intuitively see that as we move from
the left towards the right along the
curve it gets deeper so the slope of the
curve in general doesn't make sense so
let's focus our attention around this
point P what will be the slope at this
point for this let me ask you one
question is the earth flat or round
you'd probably be laughing because we
all know that the earth is almost round
in shape but notice the surroundings
around you it seems that the earth is
flat why is it so considered this circle
as the representation of the earth and
let's say you are currently situated
here if we zoom in around this portion
of the curved line we see that it
becomes less and less curved it looks
almost like a straight line so let's say
we draw a straight line only
intersecting the curve at this point we
can see that the curved line is almost
the same as the straight line we know
that this line which passes through only
one point of the curve is called the
tangent line at that point
take a moment and just observe what we
found this is the most important idea on
which calculus is built a curved line in
a very small region around a point on it
can be approximated by a straight line
this straight line is the tangent line
at this point so this solves our problem
the slope of the curve at a point will
be equal to the slope of the tangent
line at that point
and we are familiar with how to find the
slope of a straight line so how do we
find the slope of the tangent line at
this point but before answering this
question let's look at why are we so
interested in finding the slope we will
continue this in the next part
previously we saw what we meant by a
function between two variables x and y a
function tells us how the value of one
variable depends on another variable so
if the value of x changes from X naught
to X naught plus Delta X then the value
of Y will also change from why not - why
not plus Delta Y now look at this ratio
Delta Y over Delta X it tells us the
rate at which the value of y changes in
proportion to the change in X for
example consider these two ratios as the
ratio in the second case is greater the
value of y will change relatively faster
here this rate of change for a function
is actually related to the slope of a
curve let's see how let's say if the
graph of this function is a straight
line like this X naught Y naught is this
point and when the value of x changes by
Delta X we reach this point now consider
the ratio Delta Y over Delta X we saw
earlier that for a straight line this
ratio is the measure of its steepness
so the rate of change in Y with respect
to X is equal to the slope of this line
now we can see that for a straight line
its slope is constant throughout so its
rate of change will also be constant but
what if instead of this the graph of the
function is given by a curved line the
slope at a point tells us the rate of
change at that point we've seen earlier
that in a very small region around a
point the curve can be thought of as a
straight line this is the tangent line
at this point so we see that the slope
of this line is equal to the rate of
change here but now we can see that
depending on the point on the curve the
slope will change so this means
depending on the value of the X variable
the rate of change will also vary now
let's look at an example to understand
this let's say if this function y is the
distance traveled by an object in motion
and X is the time taken for the distance
traveled then the rate of change in Y
with respect to X will be equal to the
speed of the object in the first case we
know that the rate of change is constant
so the speed of the object will be
constant throughout its motion while in
the second case the rate of change is
not constant so here this rate will tell
us the instantaneous speed of the object
for this reason the rate of change for a
function at a particular value of x x
naught is called as the instantaneous
rate of change at X naught so to
conclude a very small portion of a curve
around a point can be approximated by
the tangent line at that point the slope
of this tangent line tells us the
instantaneous rate of change of the
function at that point but how do we
find this slope or instantaneous rate of
change do you remember that in one of
our previous videos we found the
instantaneous speed of an object
to find the instantaneous speed we have
to use the process of differentiation
let's say we want to find the
instantaneous speed at this point P that
is at the time instant X naught for this
we first find the average speed for some
time interval Delta X at X naught the
distance covered will be this and at X
naught plus Delta X it will be this so
the average speed in the time interval
Delta X will be equal to this for a
function this ratio is called as the
average rate of change now let's say we
draw a straight line between these two
points it's called the secant line we
see that the slope of the secant line
will be equal to the average speed in
the time interval Delta X so we see that
the average rate of change between two
values of X is equal to the slope of the
secant line between the corresponding
points on the curve now what's the next
step how do we find the instantaneous
speed from this average speed for this
we find the average speed in shorter
time intervals that is as Delta X tends
to 0 we say that when the limit Delta X
tends to 0 the average speed approaches
the instantaneous speed this
instantaneous speed is the instantaneous
rate of change at X naught now what
happens to the secant line as Delta X
tends to 0 let's say we find the average
rate of change between points P and Q 1
Q 2 and so on we can see that as Delta X
tends to 0 these points come closer and
closer to the point P so as the limit
Delta X tends to 0 the secant line will
pass through only one point P on the
curve that is the secant line approaches
the tangent line
this is how using the process of
differentiation we find the
instantaneous rate of change of a
function or the slope of a tangent line
now here instead of writing the
instantaneous rate of change in Y with
respect to X at X naught we say that the
derivative of the function at X naught
is this the derivative is usually
denoted by the symbol divided by DX so
we saw here that the derivative of the
function at a particular value of x is
its instantaneous rate of change at that
point in the next lesson we will further
explore the concept of derivatives we
will see how to exactly find the
derivative for a particular function
also we will understand what the symbol
means intuitively subscribe to our
channel to stay updated
[Music]